et on ouvre cette matinale par cette
grâce accordé la semaine dernière à 9
indépendantistes catalans cette grâce
suffira-t-elle à apaiser les tensions
entre le pouvoir central et la région
catalane
réponse dans quelques heures puisque le
président de la région doit rencontrer
aujourd'hui le premier ministre espagnol
ce dernier assure qu'il veut tourner la
page de l'affrontement avec la région
indépendantiste sauf que des sanctions
sévères demeure sur des dizaines
d'autonomistes voyez les précisions de
notre correspondante sur place
clémentine laura les discussions
reprennent entre madrid et barcelone
pedro sanchez premier ministre espagnol
et pereira connaissent président catalan
se rencontrent ce jeudi pour discuter
des aspirations politiques
les indépendantistes catalans ça n'était
pas arrivé depuis février dernier en
fait depuis les dernières élections
régionales alors à cette rencontre
chacun vient avec ses propres objectifs
d'un côté les indépendantistes catalans
souhaitent un référendum
d'autodétermination et une amnistie
totale de leurs dirigeants politiques
ceux-là même qui avait été condamné
après la tentative de sédition en 2017
de l'autre côté le gouvernement espagnol
se montre beaucoup plus petit vince aux
intentions tout ce que l'on sait c'est
que pedro sanchez soit des propositions
transversale autrement dit il veut
tendre la main à barcelone mais il
espère en contrepartie que les catalans
fasse un pas vers lui dans les deux cas
tout le monde se met d'accord pour dire
que cette rencontre marque une nouvelle
étape dans les relations madrid
barcelone d'ailleurs pedro sanchez et
paieraient argonnaise se sont déjà
rencontrés ce dimanche ici même à
barcelone à l'occasion du mans global
congress mais ce mardi ce sera à madrid
se tiendra la réunion au siège du
gouvernement espagnol